hey it's me again I want to answer the
question if you have arthritis should
you avoid the nightshade vegetables that
would be potato tomato pepper and
eggplant okay
these foods contain a natural pesticide
called solanine which is mainly in the
least in the stems but it's very small
small trace amounts in the actual potato
tomato pepper or eggplant so the answer
is no you do not have to worry about it
I mean if you if you have an allergy to
this chemical or you have a sensitivity
which is very rare you're going to
notice a worsening in your arthritis as
soon as you take it but you're probably
going to notice more GI problems
migraines cramps things like that with
one exception of the potato if the
potato is sprouting returning green that
means it does have more of this chemical
and you would want to avoid it your body
has the ability to detoxify this
naturally and the benefits from these
foods - the potato by the way because
the starch is very very high in
nutrients phytonutrients and in
anti-inflammatory properties thanks for
watching hi guys hey listen I created a
pretty amazing evaluation quiz down
below that actually analyzes your
symptoms to find the cause the root
cause of all of your symptoms the most
likely cause so take the quiz now and
we'll send you report